let's do some subtraction and actually
in these videos i'm going to switch
between the singapore math way of
visualizing things and the soul way of
visualizing things and actually they're
they're the exact same way
i find the sound way to be more
intuitive because i am sal anyway let's
do some problems
let's do
three thousand
two hundred
and forty six
minus
one thousand 1634
and let's do it with the singapore math
visualization
of what's going on
so this is the thousands
this
is the hundreds
this is the tens
and this is the ones
so let's draw the top number three
thousand
well that's three thousand one thousand
two thousand
and three thousand
two hundred
one hundred
two hundred
forty so that's four tens
one ten
two ten
three tens
four tens
and then six one two three four five six
and these are all
these are all ones
and we're going to subtract
1634 from it so whenever we do
subtraction and i think in a couple of
videos we sample this a little bit with
three digits we just have to make sure
that the number below
the number above is smaller so that we
can just do subtraction each of the
places but if we go
you know you could go right to left or
left to right you could see that well
one thousand is less than three thousand
so that's cool
six thousand is not less than two
thousand sorry 600 is not less than 200
so that's not cool so we're going to
have to do something here but then we
have 30 is less than 40. that's okay and
4 is less than 6. so somehow we have to
be able to get a larger number up here
in the hundreds place
and the way we do that
the way i you know when i learned it in
the
early 80s they called it borrowing and
even that wasn't a real term because
you're not borrowing from a number
another number place you're taking it
you're never giving the number back
but anyway i think now and it's called
regrouping but it's all the same thing
so what do you do for example we're in
the hundreds place right we have two
hundreds and we have to take out six
hundreds from this right
so how do we do that well what we do is
we can take a thousand
and we can turn it into ten hundreds
so let's take this thousand
and let's turn it into ten hundreds
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten each of those are a hundred
hundred hundred
hundred
hundred
hundred hundred
hundred hundred
hundred that's ten hundreds right so we
got rid of this thousand so how do we
draw it here
well we got rid of one thousand
so we had three but we cashed in one of
them
so now we only have two left right one
two
and then how many hundreds do we have we
have these 10 plus 2 we have 12
hundreds
12 hundreds and now every number on the
bottom is less than the number on the
top and we can subtract
so six minus four so six minus one two
three four is two
four minus three so we have four minus
one two three is one
twelve minus six
one two three four five six and we have
six left
and you know the 12 minus six is six and
then two minus one this one's not there
anymore so we have two take out one you
just have one left one thousand six
hundred and twelve
so let's do the other problems that they
have here
and i'll skip around a little bit
because i think the important thing is
that you get the big picture and then
after you get the big picture
the rest of the problems are really just
a little bit of practice
so let's do
5400
so i'm going to do 5340
minus 6. and now i'm going to do it
sal's way and you'll see it's really the
same thing as a singapore math way it's
just a slightly different way of
thinking about it so how can we write 5
340 what's a different way of writing it
well 5 340 is the same thing as 5 000
plus
300
plus 40
plus zero ones right 5 340
and we're going to subtract that how do
we write six
well six is just six ones right and
there's nothing else in any of the other
places
so how do we do that
well in the ones place we have a zero
and we want to take a six away from it
you can't do that and we will in the
future when we do negative numbers but
for what we do right now you can't take
a six from a zero so what do you do
well let's take 10 away from the
tens place so let's take 10 from here
so this becomes 30
and let's put that 10 here
and how do we do it here how does that
look well this becomes a 3
and then this becomes a 10.
and now we can subtract what's 10 minus
6
what's 10 minus 6 it's 4
plus 30
plus 300
plus
5 000
or we do it on this side 10 minus 6 is
4. 3 minus nothing is 3. 3 minus nothing
is 3. 5 minus nothing is 5.
and there you have it 5 334 is equal to
5 000 plus 300 plus 30 plus 4.
let's do another one
actually all of these are kind of of the
same nature but yeah
doesn't hurt to go through them they do
it where you have to borrow in the tens
place and then you have to borrow the
hundreds place but they're all
kind of the same notion so let's do
seven thousand
minus
three hundred
well if we write it out like this seven
thousand is really just
seven thousand plus zero hundreds plus
zero tens plus zero ones
three hundred is three hundred
plus zero tens plus zero ones
and so we wanna subtract this 300 from
the zero hundreds how do we do that
well let's take one of the thousands
from the seven thousand so we're going
to take a thousand away
so we only have six thousand left and
we're going to put that thousand here
so if we do that well how does this look
on this side well that becomes a six and
this becomes a ten right ten hundred is
a thousand
this
ten hundred is the same thing as this
thousand this six thousand is the same
thing as that six thousand and now we
can subtract zero minus zero is zero
zero minus zero is zero ten minus three
is seven six minus nothing is six and we
did the same thing here zero minus zero
is zero zero minus zero
thousand minus three hundred is seven
hundred
and then six thousand minus nothing is
six thousand so six thousand seven
hundred is equal to
six thousand plus seven hundred plus
zero tens plus zero
let's see if we can do a harder one now
this one looks interesting
problem number six on page 30.
problem number six
and i will do it in blue
so two thousand
four hundred
and thirty five
minus
one thousand
two hundred and sixty eight so let's
think about this let's write it in what
i call expanded form
but that's 2 000
plus 400
plus 30
plus 5 right 2 435
these are equivalent and then the bottom
number is one thousand
plus two hundred
plus
sixty plus eight and you see why this is
really the same thing is that singapore
math where i draw out the tables and i
draw the disks and actually i'm open to
your feedback on which one you prefer
which one you find
more intuitive this one obviously takes
less time and it's something that you
might you know you could probably do on
the side of your paper if you really
want to get an intuition of what's
happening
so let's try to subtract
so remember the number on the bottom if
you want to subtract has to be less than
the number on the top or the number
right above it one is less than two two
is less than four six is not less than
three and eight is not less than five so
neither of these are cool so what can we
do
these worked out but we can't subtract
60 from 30.
so what can we do well let's take one of
the let's take a 100 from 400
so we're going to make that into 300 and
add that hundred here
so 130. all we did is we shifted 100
from the 400 to the 30. that's all we
did
okay but now we still have this problem
here where the eight is is greater than
the five so let's take a 10
from this 130
and it becomes 120 i'm running out of
space
that's 120. and i took the 10 i'll shift
it here so this becomes 15.
so i know you can't read so this is 300
this is 120
this is 15. and now we're ready to
subtract actually before we subtract
let's see how it look you know if you
weren't doing an expanded form
we took 100 from the 4 from the 400 and
we added it to the 30. so this became a
three
and then the 30 became 130 right 13 in
the tenths place is 130
and then we said
well we need this 5 isn't large enough
so let's take 10 from the tens place so
instead of having 13 tens we're going to
have 12 tens
and add add that to the 5 so the 5
becomes a 15. that's exactly what we did
at this end right it's just the only
difference is we wrote the zeros so that
you see that you know twelve tens is a
hundred twenty three hundreds is three
hundred and fifteen is of course three
fifteen
now we can subtract fifteen minus eight
is seven twelve minus six is six three
minus two is one two minus one is one
or fifteen minus eight is seven
hundred twenty minus sixty is sixty
three hundred minus two hundred is one
hundred
two thousand minus one thousand
is one thousand
and just so you remember this one
represents this one thousand
this one
represents one hundred and how do i know
that because of its place it's place
value
this 6
represents this 60
and then of course the 7
is
represents that 7 or they represent each
other
do another one and now i'll actually oh
actually i'm already on the 11th
actually let me just keep going because
i think now that i'm a youtube partner
they let me do videos for as long as i
want
which could be dangerous
i might keep i might keep going forever
i might never stop because this is just
so much fun
so i'll do problem number 10 on page 32.
and problem number 10 we have 6 000
six thousand minus two hundred
and fifty seven
i'm gonna do it the singapore math way
so let's say this is the thousands place
let's write th for thousands
this is the hundreds place
this is the tens
tens
this is the ones
the ones
okay so when we subtract we want to see
if the number uh above is greater than
the number below well 0 is not greater
than 2 0 is not greater than 5 0 is not
greater than 7. so we have an issue so
how do we do this well first let's just
represent the 6 000 over here
so 6 000 is six thousands literally
one thousand
two thousand
three thousand i'm writing making these
two big
four thousand
five thousand
and six thousand
and then we have no hundreds tens or
ones right
but we need hundreds of tens or one so
we can subtract
so what can we do well let's take one of
these thousands and convert them to ten
hundreds so i'm going to take
this thousand
and convert it to ten hundreds right ten
hundred so i have one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten all of
those are a hundred
i think you know those are 100
i don't have to write 100 in each of
them
so and how does that correspond here
well i took 1 000
so i only have 5 000 left
and i converted them to ten hundreds so
now i have a ten in the hundreds place
ten hundreds
well the hundreds place looks good now
but now the tens place i have
zero is less than five so what can i do
let me take one of these
ten hundreds these newly cashed out ten
hundreds and turn them into ten tens so
if i take this one let's take that one
and i will convert it to ten tens right
this is one hundred that i just took so
that's ten ten so it's one two 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 and each of these are 10.
so what did i do i took one of my 10
hundreds so now i have 9
and i have 10 tens
well that might seem like we're done now
but we still have a problem in the ones
place seven is greater than zero which
is not acceptable so let's do the same
thing let's take one of these tens
this is a ten right each of these are
ten let's take one of them away and
convert into 10 ones 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10.
and so we took one of these 10 tens so
we have 9 left and we have 10 ones
now we are ready to subtract 10 minus 7
is 3 or 10 minus 7. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7. we
have 3 left
9 minus 5 this one was already gone so 1
2 3 4 5 is 4.
nine minus two is seven all right we
take out one two we have seven left and
then five minus nothing so five thousand
seven hundred
and forty three
let's do well actually i'm already
running at 15 minutes so i will do the
next problem in the next video see you
soon